it's crunchy sweet and a great way of
repurposing leftover sourdough starter
so right now a lot of people are
experimenting with sourdough starters
and making their own sourdough bread my
co-worker katie has done two great
videos one on how to make your own
starter and another on how to bake your
own bread now having a sourdough starter
requires you to feed it constantly and
with that you have to discard the excess
which can seem and is a little bit
wasteful luckily you don't have to throw
away the excess sourdough starter there
are tons of different recipes you can
make using it so today i'm going to be
using my excess sourdough starter to
make fried chicken and sourdough waffles
for myself and my roommate so without
further ado let's get cooking
i have here one cup of whole milk and
i'm adding lemon juice to it i'm going
to let this sit and curl for a minute
and bring in my chicken
i'm using chicken thighs for this recipe
because they're super flavorful and
they're a bit more forgiving to cook if
you don't have chicken thighs don't
worry just go ahead and use whatever
chicken you may prefer i'm going to
generously coat this in salt
and pepper
and i'm going to do the same thing on
the other side
after at this point i'm going to
transfer my chicken thighs to a ziploc
bag
pour over my buttermilk
and now i'm just going to take this to
the fridge to let it marinate for about
a half hour so i'm just going to get
started on my breading so in a bowl here
i'm going to add all purpose flour
baking powder onion powder garlic powder
and salt and i'm just going to whisk
until combined next i'm going to add
more homemade buttermilk so i have my
whole milk and my lemon juice i'm just
going to combine the two of them you
don't want to pour it all in at once
we're not making like a fully liquid
batter this is going to allow it to
clump up and you're going to get those
nice crispy little bits on the outside
of your chicken so a little bit of
buttermilk fold that in
it's going to kind of start to resemble
wet sand so i'm just going to get that
nice and incorporated
and as you can see my breading has
formed an almost shaggy like consistency
you've got these little nice pebbly bits
that are going to flake up on the
outside that means it's time to bring in
my chicken and coat everything so i'm
going to take my chicken directly from
the bag place it into my flour get it
nice and coated and then just flip and
i'm going to press to kind of get those
flaky bits in there
you can see where all the little
breading bits have kind of coated it i'm
just going to place on a wire rack
i'm going to do the same thing with the
rest of my chicken the last thing we
have to do with it is fry it i have a
pot of oil here at about 350 degrees
fahrenheit and i'm going to fry my
chicken in batches two pieces at a time
and lower it in
and
lower it in
so i'm just gonna let this go for about
five to seven minutes checking on it
make sure the color is nice you want the
internal temperature to reach 165 that's
how you know it's done
there's something extremely magical
about watching things fry
alrighty so my chicken looks perfect at
this point so i'm just gonna pull it out
nice and golden brown and i'll place on
a paper towel lined sheet
and then i'm just gonna repeat with my
remaining two pieces
and when you're frying chicken it's
always important to make sure you lay it
away from you in the oil that way none
of it splashes up and burns you all of
my chicken is fried at this point so i'm
just going to remove it from the oil
and then hitting it with a little bit of
salt so i'm just going to toss my
chicken in the oven right now it's set
at about 250 degrees it's not to cook it
just to keep it warm and i'm gonna get
started on my sourdough waffles so in a
large bowl i'm going to combine
all-purpose flour sugar baking powder
and salt and then i'm just going to
whisk until incorporated so now i'm on
my wet ingredients and this is where my
sourdough discard is going to come in
i'm going to add two eggs
of course i'm going to add buttermilk
now i'm going to add my sourdough
discard
now unlike sourdough bread where your
starter has a lot of the yeast that
contributes to the rise in the bread
this is just going to add flavor it's
not going to help my waffles rise all
that much and then finally i'm going to
add my butter and i'm just going to
whisk this until it's nice and combined
and that looks nice and incorporated to
me so now it's time to put everything
together so my dry ingredients are back
i'm just going to add the wet to it and
i'm going to lift this until nice and
combined and i like to go down the sides
just to make sure everything is nice and
incorporated and my batter is basically
done at this point so i'm going to get
my waffle iron and make some waffles it
is the moment of truth my waffle maker
is preheated all i need to do is add my
batter kind of open her up now these
only need about a half cup of batter in
them another one because i don't have a
half cup measuring cup right now and i'm
just going to close it right up and
you're going to let this cook for about
four to six minutes until it's the exact
amount of doneness that you want
looks like it's cooking all right so
it's been about four minutes at this
point i just want to take a little peek
it's looking done enough for me i got
chalked this one up to the oh
wow
i'm just going to repeat this with the
remaining waffles
[Music]
and there you go that is
the last of our waffles all right
so we have fried chicken pretty standard
fried chicken using chicken thighs and
then we have a waffle here but i use the
discard from a sourdough starter so it
should have just like a little bit of
that kind of tartness that comes with
sourdough oh my god it looks incredible
ready yeah
it was good this is why you didn't want
me to eat on camera for the last one
mm-hmm
it doesn't really have to be easy to eat
gracefully it's not attractive to eat on
camera
okay i'll cut it
i feel like my mother right now
well
oh am i supposed to say something else
well i wanted to know what your thoughts
were do you like it would you eat it
again disgusting i think you need to do
another round just to get it right
mm-hmm and you want to try that one too
yeah okay what are your thoughts do you
like it do you dislike it i mean
it's incredible i'll never make it for
myself you know
it's a good thing i live with you but
but yeah you should definitely make this
again all right well
that is fried chicken and sourdough
waffles using leftover starter if
there's other recipes you want us to try
involve can you hold for a second
if there's other recipes you want us to
try let us know in the comments below
and maybe we'll give it a shot this
recipe will be on tasty.com if you're
interested and until then you want to go
eat this off camera i would love to
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you